et on pourrait peut-être travailler en
équipes n'ont en effet c'est à
l'escargot
qu'est-ce qui attend que ça à faire sur
un escargot bon ça suffit cette équipe
technique a besoin d'un changement de
direction
regardez bien et prenez-en de la graine
et cric et crac ou récents ajouts et
thalys est née roser population
attention génération massage des pieds
de haut
l'accusation et la twa toussaint et
m'attendais l'accession complètement fou
vous pouvoir tu crois que j'étais normal
mais je sentais une voiture non est ce
que tu es une voiture non alors arrête
de télécoms une facture est maintenant
en piste on est comme au boulot